so the space shuttle discovery has flown
its last mission it has been towed over
the nation's capital like a bruised
Chevy after a demolition derby before
being deposited at the udvar-hazy Air
and Space Museum in Northern Virginia
other space Junkers Atlantis and
endeavour they're being retired like
Rhett favre and a pair of Crocs bringing
an end to an underwhelming three decades
of fruitless and tragic exploration of
low-earth orbiting patterns now let's
face it once we beat the Russians to the
moon the national rocket grew limper
than Liberace at a speculum convention
nASA has been dining out on a single
1969 hit longer than Zager and Evans the
good news is that amateur hour is now
over and the private space race has
begun we're too cold war superpowers
failed let a thousand business plans
bloom the future of spaces in the hands
of guys behind amazon paypal and virgin
the force of competition will create
endless possibilities and unimaginable
technologies then we're talking about
how the space program brought us tang
and tempur-pedic mattresses we're going
to Mars baby business class virgins
Richard Branson has already signed out
more stars than there are in heaven and
his regular press releases read like TMZ
Ashton Kutcher Katy Perry and Angelina
Jolie have all reserved space on the
first civilian flights to the great
beyond the international space station
will continue as a government-run
intergalactic DMV but at least the
spaceships slepping materials and
mouth-breathers to and from will soon be
operated by private vendors at an
expected ninety percent discount that
should put plenty more celebrities and
civilians in the mood to join the thirty
mile high club gir the founder of budget
suites Robert Bigelow has already
launched experimental modules he's
dreaming of putting affordable hotels
complete with been spread soaked an
alien DNA they're going in orbit and
paypal's Elon Musk has said he wants to
die on Mars preferably in a colony
established by SpaceX his company that's
hell-bent not just on leaving Earth but
getting you to the red planet in style
now nobody knows exactly how private
space exploration
entrepreneurship will play out but it's
a lock the next 30 years won't resemble
our government runs space programs
decades-long failure to launch anything
more inspiring than josie and the
pussycats in outer space space out
you